Please give a warm round of applause and welcome to the stage and Matthew
Claudel.
[inaudible].
Thank you.
Thanks everyone for coming today.
My name is Matthew Claudel and I'm a researcher at Mit in the Department of
urban planning and also with Mit lab for innovation,
science and policy.
And I'm here today to talk about the evolution and growth of urban innovation.
So we live in a widely publicized urban era.
It's the reason why sidewalk labs exists.
The reason why I do what I do,
and um,
this global shift to cities is bringing in extraordinary set of challenges.
For example,
food production and agriculture,
transportation,
equitable governance,
these are all huge issues.
But I also think that the metropolitan shift is giving us an extraordinary set
of tools to answer those challenges.
So my work deals broadly with the question of how to generate,
test and scale new urban technologies in a way that's equitable,
robust,
and citizen centric.
Now obviously that's a huge topic.
So for today's presentation,
I've broken it down into four main categories.
The first of these is Futurecraft,
which is a new methodology that I developed in a recent book with Carlo Ratti,
which you can find back there.
Um,
the second is design x,
which is a program that we just launched it MIT this semester and it's intended
to refocus design education towards entrepreneurship and urban innovation.
Thirdly,
I'll talk a bit about,
um,
dynamic urbanisms these sorts of prototypes that I've seen for what I think of
as a new mode of city making.
And finally bringing that all together,
synthesizing it into the question of now what,
what do we do with all this?
How do we act?
So we're talking about the future of cities.
I want to start with something that we all love Paleo futures.
Um,
I think for as long as people have been building cities,
we've also been imagining what the future of the city will look like,
what,
what's going to happen tomorrow?
Everything from Fritz Lang's metropolis to minority report,
they're all imagining this future city.
So out of this scrap heap of urban visions,
I chose one from my hometown of Boston.
Um,
this is an article that ran in the Boston Globe in the year 1906,
I believe,
or sorry,
1900 in which the authors imagined what Boston would look like at the turn of
the millennium.
So you can see,
he imagined that everyone will own an auto something or other interesting didn't
come to pass,
but I guarantee you he could not have imagined the long chain of ideation of
innovation,
of technology development,
including the internet,
including Google.
Actually that led to everyone having a personal driver.
This was a radical vision that could never have existed back then.
So if you imagine that kind of long chain of,
of ideas and technologies and innovations and you look at them developing over
time,
you get something a little bit like this.
This is one of the earliest diagrams of that concept.
It's by,
um,
Augustus Pitt rivers from 1906.
It's called the evolution of culture.
And in it he imagines how a simple stick is developed,
iterated into any number of weapons and tools.
And to me,
what,
when I see this,
I see an underlying evolutionary metaphor.
You can think of the development of technology as a sort of synthetic evolution.
Yeah.
Now if we have synthetic evolution,
I think the role of designers is actually to introduce mutations into that
progress to introduce mutations into the development of synthetic evolution.
Now as designers,
um,
it's a little bit different than the biological world and in the biological
world,
mutations are entirely random.
They happen with each generation and it's kind of the scattershot approach.
As designers,
we have the obligation and the luxury to think about how things ought to be.
In the words of Herbert Simon,
we're,
we aim at changing existing situations into preferred ones,
which is great,
but it's not quite that simple because why should the designer be the one to
choose how things ought to be.
Why should the responsibility to adjudicate between preferred situations and not
preferred situations be vested only in designers?
Um,
I think that the process of public debate and public scrutiny,
especially when you're talking about urban technologies in public space should
be collectively held.
Um,
I think that is analogous almost to the force of natural selection in the
biological yeah.
World.
So this whole framework is what we call Futurecraft.
And that's sort of the,
the framework onto which we built the city of tomorrow book.
And I want a diagram a bit how it works.
So here we are today positioned with respect to the future.
You can take any topic and see where it is today.
For example,
transportation.
And you can look back and see all of the developments in iterations and
technologies that led us to where we are today and carrying forward that
momentum.
You can see where it's going to,
where it might go in five years in 10 years down the line.
And then you have this sort of like future scenario,
this vision of what the city might look like in 10 years.
And into that scenario you can propose a design project.
So going back to transportation,
we know there was the Ford model t we know there was unleaded gasoline.
Today's,
there's a Tesla we could imagine in the near future,
what if every car we're autonomous.
And then you can begin to design into that scenario.
So,
for example,
in a future of autonomous cars,
you can rethink what a car looks like.
You can design new ride sharing interactions.
You can also rethink what a parking lot needs to be now that we don't need to
park our cars anymore.
So of course that design project exists not in the future,
but today.
And because it does,
it can actually influence the development of synthetic evolution over the next
five,
10 15 years.
And in 2031 15 years down the line,
we're going to look back at 2016 and say,
wow,
that was crazy.
I can't believe that we thought the city of tomorrow would look like this.
But at least it gave us momentum.
And it gave us a context into which to develop a design project.
And that again is this notion of Futurecraft a to quote Anthony Dunne and Fiona
Raby.
Our role is to unlock people's imaginations and generate alternatives.
So in this book,
we use that methodology,
this framework to look at a number of what if scenarios.
So,
for example,
what if humanity could collectively,
right as we read,
what if drones merged with the environment?
I'll talk a bit more about that one later.
And this little collection of projects is a good snapshot of the kinds of work
that we were doing at the senseable city lab.
The kinds of work that I got to be involved with,
with an incredible team of people,
uh,
researchers,
designers,
computer scientists,
technologists.
But what,
what struck me is that many of these projects don't go beyond the prototype
phase.
And of course as a research lab,
you're not intending to,
to kind of develop businesses,
but at the same time,
our cities need this kind of thinking.
Our cities need these sorts of technologies to be integrated to solve the
challenges that we face today.
And that really led us to this idea for design X.
I'm a new program that refocuses education towards urban innovation and all.
Explain a bit more about what that means.
Um,
it builds on a lot of momentum that's happening right now at the institute.
To quote Ed Roberts,
who's a pioneer of innovation at MIT.
Universities must create a culture and programs that make entrepreneurship
widely accessible.
And at Mit,
obviously that's nothing new.
If you look back during World War II in the 1940s,
um,
conditions were absolutely perfect.
There was high demand with the war effort,
there was low funding,
so people were really thinking creatively about how to do things differently.
Um,
there were a lot of partnerships with government and industry and a unique
organizational model.
What I mean by that is that MIT put up some really shabby buildings and crammed
everyone in there and told them to work really hard.
Um,
building 20 is kind of the famous example,
the Rad lab,
and out of that building,
um,
it seems incredible,
but radar,
microwave technology,
bows,
acoustics,
the first video game,
Chomsky,
linguistics,
I mean it was really across the board.
I'm one of the most vibrant and innovative hotspots in the 20th century.
And if you look at the development of innovation over the course of the 20th
century,
actually we've only skyrocketed from there.
So right here in uh,
1946 in the middle of the war you can see a little blip.
And here we are in 2014.
So not only are we producing more patents,
those patents are more collaborative and I think that has a lot to do with the
space of campus.
As an architect,
I wanted to understand how does the physical architecture of the campus and
proximity effect the way in which people collaborate.
So this is what it looks like.
Um,
and the campus is organized obviously according to departments,
labs and centers.
These are things with a discreet buildings,
but there are also some a spacial connections like initiatives and institutes.
I mentioned before,
the Innovation Initiative that I'm a part of.
So this little visualization shows over time how people are collaborating with
papers and patents and you can see sort of hotspots are moving across the campus
and different amounts of activity for patents and papers.
Um,
and I actually found a consistent curve interestingly,
um,
modeled by negative exponential function where the more the closer you are,
the more likely you are to collaborate with someone.
This is similar to,
for example,
um,
pollination with seeds.
Like the closer you are to a tree or a flower,
the more likely you are to find a seat.
Um,
and the same holds true with a remarkable degree of confidence,
um,
with ideas with collaboration.
And this is true even for cross departmental collaboration.
So people who are in a completely different field.
So how do those departments collaborate?
Um,
this is a set of graphs that shows the connections between departments over
time,
with papers and patents.
And if you take this same information,
you can actually represent that as a network.
So this is the collaboration network at MIT where each node is a researcher and
they're colored according to their department and sized according to their
output.
And then the connections between the nodes are the strength of a collaboration.
And this accounts for the number of papers and the total number of authors on
those papers.
So these,
um,
these researchers are collaborating and you could think of those clusters as
community.
So this is with a,
a community detection algorithm.
We saw which groups are more likely to collaborate with each other than with
anyone else.
Um,
and you,
you can imagine these as almost like cliques of scientists.
Um,
and zooming into those,
as you could expect,
Sloan School of Management and economics tend to collaborate a lot with each
other.
The earth atmosphere and planetary science guys that are on their own planet.
I'm doing their own thing and not collaborating,
but we're really struck me here is that design is missing.
The designers,
the architects,
the planners are not collaborating with anyone else,
which seems crazy because so many of the innovations that are coming out of Mit,
our urban facing.
So for example,
we have colleagues who are doing smart sewer monitoring and um,
I studied architecture so I can kind of confidently bash it a little bit,
but I think design education is actually pretty archaic.
So this is what,
how it went in the 1920s.
And essentially the same thing is happening today.
Um,
when it comes to practice design practice in architecture and planning is also
pretty archaic.
It's not innovation driven.
It's not scalable.
It's a service for a fee model.
So it's more of the studio,
the Lea.
And that's reflected also in trends across the United States.
Here you can see a map of accelerators and funding across the United States.
And what strikes me about this is that in Boston there are very few
accelerators.
There are very few academic accelerators and there's basically nothing for urban
science,
for planning,
for architecture.
So all this comes together into an idea for design x.
And this is a new program situated in the school of architecture and planning
the idea behind it being to redirect education towards real challenges and real
solutions to bring in partners from industry,
um,
and to focus the students and enable them to launch and grow entrepreneurial
ventures for the build environment.
Um,
I can speak more about this later,
but the idea is to link the five different departments in the school of
architecture and planning.
That includes the media,
lab,
art,
culture,
technology,
urban planning center for real estate,
um,
and offer all of the services and all of the resources that exist,
in the,
in the wider world as an accelerator.
So that includes mentorship,
that includes funding,
things like that.
Um,
our broader agenda is to advance design,
to empower students to link academia and practice and to research this kind of
emerging field that we think of as design innovation.
And so to better understand what that really looks like,
we actually,
um,
scouted out all of the entrepreneurship that's come out of MIT.
And,
uh,
despite the lack of resources,
we actually found some really exciting companies that came out of the school,
for example,
form labs,
um,
[inaudible],
which is this amazing like mushroom suit that you get buried in after you die.
And it sort of takes care of you.
Things like mapped well,
which calculates the solar energy potential of every building in a city.
This is really exciting.
So digging more into this,
I wanted to understand what is urban innovation really look like?
What cities are doing this,
what companies are doing this?
And that's what I think of as dynamic urbanism.
So I want to show a few prototypes of this new form of city making.
I think it has four main components.
Um,
there are obviously many more,
but I'll focus on these specifically,
which are concept,
finance,
deployment and regulation.
So starting off with concept,
um,
more and more you see that ideation is happening by and for citizens.
These are people who have a knowledge of what the city looks like,
what they need from a city,
um,
how they envision their neighborhood and begin to introduce these feedback
loops,
almost empowering people to design that sort of design and franchisement.
And this can enter in any segment of the population.
People who formerly would never think of themselves as a designer and architect,
someone who has agency in their city.
A really good example of that is called is a project called the coil and
Amsterdam,
which was formerly this industrial shipyard.
It was actually,
um,
toxic soil because of all the years of,
of industrial activity.
And,
um,
the city allocated this land and put in a greenscape that remediates the soil,
but in this wonderful little winding pathway thing,
and then invited people to drag a disused canal boat into that area and start a
little design studio in there.
So now I'm architects,
artists.
Um,
kind of anyone,
any creative industry is,
is running these little studios out of old canal boats.
And what's exciting is that this is also a platform for experimenting with urban
technology.
So I'm,
I'll show a little video of an aquaponic system that they're developing there
and kind of creating this closed loop system.
Okay.
The goal is,
is before,
on the number of,
of of this recording,
it's a Kayla Sam's of course go for how to have much experimental basis about
wound there,
the greenhouse and the greenhouses,
employee excellence Alotta seen urban farming off the bill.
I need to stop [inaudible].
So this is kind of a closed loop aquaponic system.
They're developing this and actually running it in the community.
So it's,
it's going to,
um,
the storm water.
It's going to the cafe,
which exists right next door.
Secondly,
I want to talk about finance and there's this incredible,
um,
kind of set of tools that had been unlocked by crowdfunding.
So you guys are all familiar with Kickstarter,
but this is actually beginning to enter an urban space as well.
And I think finance is really important,
not only for the dollars it raises,
but also for the communities that it can create.
And once you have a critical mass of community,
you actually have much more capacity to interface with the city.
Um,
so I want to start off with a few crowdfunding real estate companies that have
come out.
Um,
so this is much more kind of dry and economic,
but um,
it's a 2.6 billion industry so far in 2016 and there are plenty of companies now
who are doing this.
Um,
it's mostly tailored to midsize developments rather than,
than the smaller the large,
but it's really kind of taken off so people can invest in real estate and much
smaller denominations.
Then formerly they would have had to as kind of a big ticket and investor.
More interesting to me is how this,
this,
uh,
begins to affect public space,
public infrastructure.
This is a project called the loop single in Rotterdam.
And it began because there was a new kind of road that cut off the main
transportation hub,
which is Rotterdam central station with the waterfront historic district.
So the citizens,
that tourists kind of,
everyone was calling for a new way of connecting those two areas.
Um,
a pedestrian connection and they solicited a design proposal.
they crowdfunded the thing and it really became a public area,
a piece of infrastructure,
but also a community space.
Here you can see the tiles that people could buy,
um,
for quite a small amount of money.
They got 8,000 citizens to contribute to this thing.
And at that point,
the city government decided to in the rest.
So they came in and sponsored the project beyond what the citizens had raised.
And thinking of that notion of implicating citizens with government,
there's an incredible company now and um,
San Francisco called neighborly.
And what they do is actually retail municipal bonds.
So formerly municipal bond market was really for those big ticket investors as
people who could put down hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And what neighborly does is allows you to invest in your community.
So,
um,
if you want to invest in a park or a school right next door,
you can choose your level of funding.
You can choose,
you're kind of expected return timeframe and do this on the order of hundreds or
thousands of dollars rather than millions.
It's really exciting and it's giving people a sense of agency and community in
their city.
Thirdly,
I want to talk about deployment and I think deployment is incredibly important
and I,
it's almost um,
a criteria for what we call urban innovation.
How do you separate urban innovation from anything else?
I really think that these need to be deployed and tested in physical space.
You need to get user feedback,
you need to be able to iterate the technology.
You need to be able to see what happens when the snow falls and the thing is
buried and freezing.
So this is a familiar example for you guys called Plus Pool in New York.
You probably heard of it.
Um,
and the idea came from a really kind of a people focused bottom up way.
when you're sitting in your apartment in the summer in New York and you're
roasting,
the only thing you want to do is jump in a pool.
But all the pools are packed.
Um,
at the same time,
the city is surrounded by water.
So this group of architects and designers thought,
why don't we make a pool that filters the Hudson and floats out in the middle of
the river?
So they went through a similar process.
They got 30,000 followers on social media.
They got 2000 funders.
And what's really interesting to me is that they actually,
um,
they built a prototype.
So here you can see the,
the campaign where you can buy a tile and contribute to building the pool.
And this is their float lab,
I think they call it,
which is now floating out in the Hudson.
Um,
they're testing the technology.
It's something completely innovative.
It's never really been done before.
And at the same time,
this thing is creating data that's publicly available so you can see kind of the
real time conditions of the Hudson and you can see how this thing is functioning
and operating.
Um,
as they progress and as they develop a very similar process went into the,
the low line.
Um,
this was an idea to reuse disused subway stations.
and again,
they raised a bunch of money on Kickstarter.
They got a bunch of support and they opened a public lab and they do a number of
programs like youth design studios and they're actually beginning to,
to work with the city to make this thing happen.
So here you can see,
uh,
a workshop that's,
that's being done with a bunch of kids.
And in the bottom,
uh,
there's there kind of construction paper vision of what this thing could be.
Of course it's totally new technology.
They're actually bringing sunlight down through a little pipe,
um,
and they've prototyped that and it's become an actual open area that you can
visit.
Now finally I want to talk about regulation.
So this is like the least sexy thing that I could possibly do.
And even in research,
people are like,
what are you going to do?
That's interesting.
That's not regulation.
But I think policy is extremely important when you're talking about urban
innovation because if something's in the street,
it's necessarily confronting with public space.
And unfortunately,
if something's innovative,
it's new.
If it's a technological development,
it's often going to be at odds with policy and regulation.
Obviously the two work at very different timescales.
So with technology it's developing weeks,
months,
and with policy and regulation,
it's developing over the course of decades.
And I think this is a huge problem.
It's actually stopping or redirecting a lot of technical development.
So I want to show an example of a project that I worked on at senseable city lab
that dealt with a really contentious form of technology right now,
which is drones.
So the idea here was to use drones as um,
a tool to sample water quality.
And the idea is that with water quality,
you really need high resolution data,
preferably in realtime,
and you need to sample it in a way that doesn't disturb the water itself.
So on the Charles River near Mit,
um,
there are these infrequent and somewhat random blooms of cyanobacteria.
And so we want to figure out why these things happen.
To do that,
we need better data.
And so the idea was to create a swarm of little drones that would share tasks
and they would fly.
And,
uh,
image the water,
but also sample it.
And then B,
I'm shooting that data up to the cloud and,
and processing it in real time.
Also making it publicly available to do that.
We,
um,
are here you can see an idea of kind of what that data would look like as an
overlay.
And we also thought it would be great to have a sort of public area where people
can go and see how the river is functioning.
Um,
see the water quality,
see the flows and see the information.
So we built a few prototypes.
Um,
this is the imaging drone and that sheriff's tasks with the water probing drone,
little pool noodles there.
Um,
and I'll show you a video now of how the thing progress.
Yeah.
So there's the existing technique now to collect data is actually rolling around
in a boat and you get samples like once a week if that.
So the,
the idea for drones came from the,
the notion of getting realtime,
um,
high resolution data.
So these data points kind of an entire grid across the river.
And here you can see our first,
a little demo.
It's in a tiny little indoor lake that we held at Mit.
And so this is the drone trying to identify where the pools of water are,
communicates those little pinpoints to the other drones.
And you're going to see in a second it comes in,
um,
actually samples the water.
Is it here is the kind of image of what this could look like.
It kind of suggestion of this being deployed on an APP,
the actual body of water.
So the next step of course would have been to test this thing,
to try it,
to fly these drones to see how it works.
Um,
we propose to do that as you saw in front of MIT at the Charles River,
at which point we got a cease and desist letter from the FAA.
Uh,
it turns out we were in violation of like dozens of drone codes and,
uh,
so we thought,
okay,
we need to,
to work with the FAA,
we need to get approval to fly these drones,
which brought us here.
This is the FAA website,
which literally looks like 1993.
Um,
and the,
the application process,
um,
for being approved would have been extremely long and laborious,
if not impossible,
um,
as a research institution.
And,
uh,
at which point our,
our funding would have been gone and the project just wouldn't have been viable.
So instead what we did was look abroad.
Um,
we brought this project to the UAE for this drones for good award.
And we also,
um,
scoped out a deployment in Rio de Janeiro.
You can see here at the bottom,
at the end of the video,
that's the logo.
And I think this is a huge problem,
right?
As it,
as an innovator,
as an entrepreneur,
as a technologist,
if the regulations are causing you either to toss your project entirely to
redirect it or to go abroad,
then we're really setting ourselves up for a lack of urban innovation.
So I'm now working on this idea of a more dynamic policy architecture.
And this would have a number of goals.
The first is to,
to recalibrate the pace of policy and technology,
so to accelerate policy and do it in a way that's,
that's recursive and datadriven.
Um,
secondly is to democratize access to deployment opportunities.
So right now,
um,
I believe there's a team at Google actually that are flying drones.
Amazon of course,
is flying drones,
researchers at MIT or not.
And so I think that that access to deployment in that access to,
um,
uh,
approval for,
for these prototypes needs to democratized.
Of course,
we want to ensure safety and valuation and forth.
If we're creating,
um,
replicable empirical data,
we can actually share that from one district to another from one city to another
and accelerate the development of a abroad technology category.
And finally,
yeah,
to promote urban innovation from new sources.
So now what,
how do we wrap this all together?
And this is really pointing towards,
um,
this book that we did called open source architecture.
And the idea behind it was,
um,
to redesign their,
the design process.
So this notion that the agency,
the power to design is in the wrong hands.
So to explain this a bit better,
I'm going to give you a one minute crash course of urban planning history.
Um,
going back to 1920,
this is Le Corbusier who I showed earlier as well.
Um,
in 1924,
he was saying things like the crooked path is the way of the donkey.
The straight path is the way of man.
So he really had this sort of comprehensive rationalist idea of planning along
came Jane Jacobs here in New York and she said,
that's absolutely wrong.
The notion of order is irreconcilably opposed to the way in which a downtown
actually works.
And she advocated for this more kind of bottom up citizen driven,
more heterogeneous approach to urban planning.
Eventually we got to this charming fellow in which urban development was really
all about the money.
It was kind of a capital land grab free for all.
Um,
I want to point out this quote,
you can never be too greedy.
And that sort of leads us to today.
And I think today we have this alternate notion of city planning,
something that's much more community focused and it's much more bottom up.
And the reason is that we have access to knowledge practices and technological
practices.
To quote Saskia Sassen,
we need to fully mobilize neighborhood and city culture.
And I think that's becoming possible now.
So the trick is to merge this kind of neighborhood scale,
the place based community scale with digital platforms that are both local and
global.
And it allows you to sort of reorient those four elements that I was talking
about before and bring in a whole number of stakeholders.
So for example,
concept brings in citizens and designers working together.
This is the idea of Futurecraft finance implicates citizens and government to
really show what needs to happen and raise support deployment,
um,
tests,
prototypes,
and it brings together entrepreneurs and designers to really be thinking about
commercializing these technologies.
And regulation,
as I said,
is a government process of course,
but it's also based on data and it happens much more quickly.
And recursively.
And again,
going back to what I said right at the beginning,
I think that a model like this will allow us to generate,
test and scale these new urban technologies.
And I really think that it could be,
um,
robust.
It can be equitable and it will of course be citizen centric.
So the reason I wanted to bring this today is that it's still very schematic.
It's very much a notion of how we could organize cities and how we could
organize digital platforms.
And you guys are doing this in practice.
You guys are working with these connective digital platforms.
You guys are working with the local and the global.
And so I really hope that this can be more of a workshop.
This can be a debate on how this thing could happen,
how it can be tangibly apply it in the streets.
Thanks.
[inaudible].
I have a question.
So you opened up the talk,
uh,
talking about,
kind of the global urbanization,
which is obviously,
you know,
take some part in in the u s but that's kind of much more global phenomenon that
now more than half the world's population lives in cities.
Um,
but it sounds like a lot of,
of sort of these initiatives work well in the West where maybe having,
um,
I'm thinking in particular about like citizen funding and perhaps some of these
other regulatory issues.
Um,
just some kind of very like us and European centric.
And one thing that I'm,
I'm a little bit,
um,
one thing that I think,
uh,
as somebody who is like a technology story designer,
it's always very easy to be,
um,
to want to work on things that are new instead of kind of wanting to solve
problems so it to solve kind of existing problems in certain locations.
So,
uh,
like the one example that I'm thinking of in particular is that I'm pretty
familiar with this Cairo.
Um,
and a lot of,
uh,
you know,
cities in South America as well where a lot of the new development towards like
building these new cities where outside of the,
the w the old urban centers,
you know,
we're Brasilia or other examples like this where designers wanted to build
things from scratch instead of kind of wanting to work with the very dirty,
messy,
uh,
kind of downtowns in slums.
Um,
and so as I guess like as you're thinking about,
um,
ways of shifting funding and policy around to address problems like this,
is that something you've thought about?
Like how do we,
how do we ensure that people are working on solving problems?
Like at the actual site instead of trying to create new kind of Utopian cities
revisions that we can shift people into.
Yeah,
no,
you bring up in an amazing point.
I think that's absolutely the right question to ask.
I should look Corbusier earlier as this.
Um,
let's say,
uh,
the,
the iconic promoter of this a Tabula Rasa,
urbanism,
I dunno if you're familiar with the project,
um,
Lipton envoy in Paris where he said we should knock down all of Paris and we
should put up these towers that are efficient.
They're rational,
the work really well.
Um,
and Brasilia you mentioned that as well,
um,
is sort of the iconic example of his ideas as built.
Um,
but I really think that urban innovation is more about figuring out those messy
problems.
I think in a physical space you have to deal with the existing conditions,
you to,
um,
acknowledge the existing city.
And it actually requires much more intelligent use of technology to,
for example,
identify slack in the system,
identify where there's unused capacity.
And that's,
I hate using these examples because they're overused,
but airbnb and Uber both identified,
um,
a sort of gap in the system that was being unused and they're filling it.
And I think there's huge possibility for doing that.
For example,
in energy production,
energy production is all about the peaks and the valleys and mitigating those,
um,
those spikes in activity.
And so I think if you,
if you introduce for example,
a smart grid model,
you're all of a sudden sharing energy between the end users and you've mitigated
the peaks and the valleys.
So I think I'm acknowledging the messy city as it is,
but thinking intelligently about how we can change it is sort of my definition
of urban innovation.
Hi,
thanks for your talk.
Um,
you spoke quite a bit about the integration of technology into the cities of the
future and also at one point mentioned some of the difficulties you had when you
ran into things like regulation.
Uh,
how much thought and planning has gone into those who would just shirk the
responsibility regulation people who might want to hack into this technology
advance city of the future.
And use it for their own,
maybe nefarious.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think you're,
you're kind of making two points there.
Um,
the first is,
uh,
the idea of,
of scaling outside of regulation.
And I think that unfortunately it sort of the emo have a lot of,
um,
a lot of startups.
So for example,
if you've taken on a round of investment,
someone's breathing down your neck to show returns,
right?
And so your incentive if you come up against the regulation is not to try and
change the regulation,
is not to try and kind of figure out how to do this in a legal way.
It's to scale as much as possible and then figure out your legal problems later.
And this has been done by a number of technologies and I don't think that's bad
in the cases of,
for example,
airbnb.
But I think that if you start,
if you start to consider challenges like wastewater and sewage,
um,
let's say Flint,
Michigan,
they could have used a water quality censoring,
um,
uh,
water quality sensor in the sewers,
for example,
a to B testing to be testing the,
the citizens water.
But as a startup,
you're never going to have the opportunity to kind of shove technology down into
the sewer.
Um,
and so this notion of scaling and then figuring out your legal problems is not
really tenable,
especially when you're,
when you're solving those kind of nitty gritty challenges of cities.
And so I think we need to find a way that regulation incentivizes technologies
to,
to acknowledge it rather than trying to scale and then figure out the legal
problems.
Um,
and then when it comes to cybersecurity,
that is a huge,
that I know very little about.
Um,
and there is people who are sort of devoting their entire careers to figuring
out,
um,
how do we secure cities as they become more and more digital.
So,
uh,
an autonomous city for example,
every car is self driving.
That sounds great until someone figures out how to hack the car system and then
you have these giant kind of a dangerous things running haywire.
Um,
so again,
that's something I don't know enough about,
but there are certainly people who are devoting a lot of energy to figuring out,
um,
urban cybersecurity.
Uh,
what changes have you seen slash what changes do you want to see in a municipal
governments
starting?
We're starting to see more,
um,
more chief digital officers.
There's,
I mentioned tech,
uh,
like literally technology literacy is really important to administrations as
well.
Um,
and educating them about these changes.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I think,
um,
they,
you,
you pointed out a really important trend,
which is that,
um,
more and more mayors offices are actually incorporating a CTO position or that
the chief digital officer,
um,
that's certainly the case here in New York.
Um,
I know that there's kind of a whole group,
I'm in the EDC who are thinking about this kind of thing.
I'm in Boston.
There's the new urban mechanics and in cities around the world also in
Amsterdam,
there's Amsterdam smart city.
Mexico City now has a similar position.
And I think that's crucial is the first step because you're never going to
introduce this sort of change.
You're never going to introduce a more dynamic policy model.
For example,
if you don't have that person in city government who's really embedded with the
mayor's office,
but also digitally literate.
Um,
and I am excited that that is becoming more of a trend and I hope that there is
linking functions between them.
So now there's,
there's a bit of,
um,
kind of collaboration and cross comparison,
but mostly it's happening,
um,
ad hoc.
So take for example,
electronic road pricing,
which is something that started,
I believe Singapore was the first one to do it and then it was replicated in
London and Stockholm and a number of other cities.
Now I think almost every city has some form of a major city has some form of
electronic road pricing.
Um,
and I think that's the kind of thing,
um,
that could be shared between the CTO offices.
I also think that,
um,
at the metropolitan level,
we need to think more about citizen engagement.
So if you look at the voter numbers,
I can't pull off the top of my head,
but people who really look at,
um,
their city government and a hold them accountable but be kind of introduced
their aspirations for the city.
At the metropolitan level,
it's really low.
And I think that's,
um,
that's the onus is on us to think about how metropolitan government can become
more and more participant with the city.
Um,
in a way that's not like long pieces of paper.
Like I was showing this FAA thing or the government websites.
I mean,
that's unfortunately the reality.
So,
um,
so getting prototypes,
getting ideas really into people's,
um,
city.
So if for example,
the,
the Lincoln Yc,
I dunno if,
if there were demos,
but as people are walking down the street,
you could,
um,
you could ask them for their feedback,
you could ask them for their interaction and then,
and then develop more along those lines.
And I think the same can be true of metropolitan process and policies.
Um,
so I guess I've somewhat of a followup question to that.
You showed the network mapping with MIT,
and I'm kind of curious because it seems a lot of these initiatives require
champions.
Did you guys do any study on sort of how these connections were made?
How to sort of foster them?
The design x is a nice way to bring that in.
But has there been more formal efforts to kind of start these engagements and
then can those lessons or do you think those lessons can be transferred to
cities?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
so the,
the study at MIT was of um,
collaborative activity with papers and patents.
So that I think,
um,
that happens kind of naturally as a function of academic research.
Um,
when you get to the city level,
I think this sorts of projects like decoy Berlin,
Amsterdam,
like looked single in Rotterdam or it's a low line in New York,
they really do need a champion.
Um,
you're absolutely right.
And I think I showed a towards the end this sort of diagram of an ecosystem
model and I think that can become something replicable.
And,
um,
it could be something that's deployed in different cities and offers a framework
for the sorts of,
um,
urban innovation that we're talking about.
I think you're right that it will still need a champion.
And if you're bringing together stakeholders like academia,
like government,
um,
like existing businesses,
they don't naturally work together really well.
So there's some good examples of this happening in pioneering cities.
Like New York,
where as an innovator you can interface with,
um,
with city government and talk about,
you know,
the low line then and how we can get this thing off the ground.
Um,
no pun intended,
but um,
but I think in,
in cities where that's perhaps not as much embedded in the culture,
um,
you will need a champion.
And I think,
uh,
going back to your question about the technology officer in cities,
maybe that's the point of entry.
Maybe that's the person who catalyzes the sorts of projects and demarcates a
district and says,
hey,
this is an area where we can prototype new technologies in a safe way,
um,
be regulating it and be kind of creating knowledge and best practice so that it
can be scaled up to the urban level.
Okay.
So there's a follow up to that.
I think the ecosystem that you mentioned,
sort of like the four circles,
it's really interesting and something we talk a lot about.
Um,
has there been any blow back when you've shown that to people in terms of like
the location of research,
first design at the beginning of the circle?
And so like how you see researchers driving concepting phases and these types of
projects.
Um,
do you want to give me pushback?
Great.
No,
I don't,
I want you to like,
I want to take your,
approve it and send it back where I came from.
Yeah.
Roast.
Because I think,
I think
we spend a lot of time at sidewalk talking about sort of how policy drives
problems that ultimately drive solutions.
Um,
and it's,
and it's an open question that we grapple with every day,
honestly,
in terms of like where the idea comes from and,
and sort of how we started driving it forward.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
I,
I really think that the idea could start at any point on that circle and
importantly it is a circle because,
um,
for example,
an idea could come from a financial justification.
So,
uh,
there's a company called convene now that's like reusing real estate,
empty real estate and almost hoteling it.
So it's like a,
we work model,
but for corporate offices and that comes from a financial justification.
Like we have this unused infrastructure,
let's figure out how to put it to work.
Um,
of course,
you can get innovation or the idea coming from a citizens,
people who say like,
I need to get from a to B,
let's figure out a better way to do that.
Um,
so I,
I think that you can sort of begin that circle at any point.
Um,
and it's a matter of bringing the different elements together.
So where I see failure unfortunately is when any one of those components,
anyone in the stake holders is trying to exist sort of on its own.
Um,
and when you,
when you're talking about cities you can't ignore for a long time anyway,
sustainably,
you can't ignore if something like regulation,
you can't ignore something like finance.
Um,
so bringing those together into the,
the sort of ecosystem is exactly the right approach.
Oh,
I just wondering what your like ideal collaboration team,
interdisciplinary team to like put your ideas into the world.
Like what would that sort of look like?
Who would you involve?
Uh,
do you need me to name names?
Like you mentioned that design is clearly like integral to a lot of these
things.
Then it's not being integrated.
Yes.
I'm just curious,
like who,
you know,
are you involving and like network scientists are involved?
Like who are you involving?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that's,
um,
that's a good question.
And I think more and more,
uh,
we're seeing this all as collaborative because individual disciplines are
becoming more specialized.
Um,
and so you need to work with people and you need to find ways of effectively
constructing a team like that.
Um,
I think for example,
network science you brought up,
um,
network science is extraordinarily cool.
I completely nerded out with that study because it's an incredible tool kit to
answer any number of questions.
You can talk about metabolic systems in a very sort of like ecosystem biology
way.
You can also talk about scientists collaborating.
You can talk about road networks.
Um,
super fascinating.
And so I think,
you know,
let's say you're working on something that seems completely unrelated,
um,
like a wastewater management system.
But if you talk to a network scientist,
there might be kind of insights from that as a very pure and abstract science
that could be applied to your tangible demonstration.
So,
um,
this is not a satisfying answer to your question,
but I do think that,
um,
sort of thinking broadly as to who can contribute to a particular idea is really
important.
And again,
it goes back to the idea of public disclosure.
So the more you can put an idea out there in the world,
the more you can kind of get criticism,
get feedback and develop the thing.
Um,
and that can happen within academia.
Obviously it can happen within any,
any number of stakeholder categories.
So it could be,
um,
you could imagine a new model for an architecture studio that's actually not an
architecture studio,
but just a network of people around the world who can decide to opt in to a
project that they find interesting.
I don't know,
I'm just speaking off the top of my head,
but that,
um,
that kind of thinking I think is more and more valid.
Hi,
thanks for the talk.
I have a question about,
uh,
into city.
So a lot of great things are happening within the city,
but what about either connections,
amount of cities?
I know that a lot of Googlers at your daily commute.
All right.
Uh,
they spend like I was on the road,
so that's a shoe,
but I can tell you this later,
I wish still spent hours on a revenue.
Is that the future of our cities?
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
so,
so as the Internet was introduced,
um,
like in the early nineties,
there was this actually very serious and very,
uh,
um,
widespread belief that the Internet was going to kill cities because all of a
sudden you could like connect from anywhere you are.
You could be on like a lounge chair on an island in The Bahamas and you could be
going to work just the same.
You can talk to anyone at any time and sort of be spatially liberated.
It would be this like neo nomadic condition.
But what we've found actually the accelerating trend is that people want to be
downtown,
people want to be in cities.
And um,
and I think a few ways to respond to that trend.
Obviously we can unlock disused capacity.
So,
for example,
city buildings around New York right now are mostly occupied but not all
occupied.
Um,
I also know that 12 hours from now in the middle of the night,
it'll be almost a complete shift of occupancy in buildings where many will stand
empty that were formerly full.
Um,
so if we can think more intelligently about how to use the infrastructure we
already have,
then,
um,
then we're making strides.
I also think that,
um,
that we might have in,
in certain areas and in certain conditions and more polycentric models.
So now,
you know,
Google was started in mountain view.
Obviously the number of people that employees can't all live in mountain view
and commute there.
Um,
and so there's offices around the world and that's,
I mean this is an obvious thing to say,
but there's digital connection technology that makes it easier to do that in a
way that you couldn't have before.
Um,
I don't know where that's heading and I don't know if the answer is that things
will become globally distributed.
I do think that place and proximity are extremely important,
especially for the ideation process.
Um,
and this is really what I was,
what I was angling on with that study of MIT was figuring out how,
um,
proximity,
even someone down the hallway is important for that collaborative activity.
Um,
so sure it's easy to schedule a meeting with someone and in Taipei,
but it's really difficult to come up with a new idea.
And,
and I think that,
um,
having these kinds of spacial centers where people agglomerate where people
bring all those different ideas.
So going back to your question about how a team works,
I mean,
I think a lot of it is serendipity.
A lot of it is kind of a shared space and shared experience,
and then you get these new ideas.
So that doesn't answer your question about the long commute.
But I do think that,
um,
downtowns and,
and having kind of a,
a cluster of people is really important.
Thanks.
[inaudible].